C R Y B A B I E S
Everyone is a bunch of CRYBABIES
Oh
Sekiro, its so difficult.
It's just like Dark Souls, But much HARDER
Its like BloodBorne but much harder
B A B I E S
Pathetic children
Pathetic beta males who don't know how to play video games
If you don't even know how to use your fingers then don't even bother playing video games. >:)
I've been seeing this my entire life, ok?
For those of you who are new to this channel, my name is PewDiePie and I'm a Professional Gamer
I have never died in a video game EVER
I bet no one who has played this game knew u could pick that letter up
So feel free to keep watching, cause we gonna find literally all the INS and OUTS
See, I know how to jump
in, near jump wall?
look at that. I figured out already-
How you wall jump
I bet no one, E V E R, figured out how to wall jump
...so far.
I'm doing extremely well
ZERO DEATHS BABY
Can we add a death counter up in the corner?
deaths: Z E R O
wall hug
okay
Look at that.
See I don't even need these patronising instructions
Because I KNOW
You see those scratches on the wall, that implies they put that there as a hint
Even if there was no scratches I wouldn't even need it
Okay?
Stealth. What do you think I don't know about stealth
I'm the stealthiest man alive
Oh god
I'm the stealthiest person on the gosh damn planet
No one has ever seen me, That's how stealthy I am
nO oNe'S eVeR dOnE tHiS
You see this?
You hang from the ledge
because there are scratches at the bottom
Game developers put that in there.
I DON'T EVEN NEED IT.
So good at games (epic gamer, eh?)
I'm so gosh damn good at games.
ZERO DEATHS!
Ye-uh!
ZERO DEATHS! Ye-uh!
Look at that, look at these movess
Look at these goddamn moves
So good at games! (still zero deaths)
Games is for children! (then you're a child, too?)
I'm playing just to prove a point. (oh)
Games is for crybabies
To think that- (?)
Real life is too scary for them
alright gimme the balls X2
just gimme the balls
JUST GIVEME THE BALLS
I ain't got time
Quick items.
Healing gourd.
Alright let's do the 'healing gourd'. EPIC
(in Japanese) shinobi shinderu
*warcry of the stealthiest man alive*
Alright, alright, alright, watch this
*watch him does epic style*
watch this gamers
aTtAcK
A-TTACK
OHH, MY GAAAAD!!!
WOW!
(bird call x2?)
Charging-
F*ck
It's fine, what that died?
That's it? That's all there's-
Oh, I didn't die
Shinobi...
G A M E R !!!
Epic! Zero deaths everyone.
Zero deaths, let's have some juice.
My god, this game is easy
Oh god.
Deflection.
Oh okay, easy.
(sword fight noises)
Come on, come on guy.
(more sword fight noises. how are you all today?)
Don't think so buddy
(epic gamer felix moment)
Zero deaths
...
I'm actually really low on health, I actually need- need some health.
Watch this, watch this gamer
E P I C stealth attack, coming right up
OHHHH, YOU JUST GOT NINJA'D!
lahlhlha you shut up when im talkin to you, you shut your mouth
Real ninjas, travel on the rooftops
Hiya!
Barely made a sound
Real shinobis...
...they move in the darkness
The darkness embraces th- (crash)
(NICE ONE)
F*ck, they put that there on purpose
They put that there on purpose!
Aw shoot... Gamers, this could be it.
BYE
Bye, gamers!
Bye gamers!
Zero deaths!
(sword fight noises)
Dozo!
(more sword fight noises)
Anotha one!
What is he doing? *chuckle*
What is he doing?
hahahahahahahha
death count : 1
death count : 2
death count : 3
death count : 4
death count : yep
Honestly this game is a lot easier than Dark Souls and BloodBorne so far.
I mean that genuinely (yea you do❤)
Look how epic I am
death count : 5
Pewdiepie Knee Slicing Champion since 2018
death count : 6
death count : 7
death count : 8
What is that move called?
(goes into silent gamer mode)
NOpe
Don't like this guy :(
Here have some ash.
”危“ is danger in chinese. *captain flies away*
how you like that little orge
(In Japanese) Oni
i know Japanese (OAO)
OOh you try to kick me now
oh gawd he changed his style
death count : 9
Are you kidding me :(
should we pretend we saw that or not 🤔
*contemplates life decisions*
well 0 deaths it is 👏 👏 👏
alright let's go for the 🍆 punches
Ooh you scared >:D
that did not even hit me QAQ
who kicks more than once D:<
(very focused papa poods)
WHAT THE F- *DEMONETIZED
WHERE DID HE COME FROM !
*absolute shocked poods*
*flashbacks at 16.09*
(Honestly this game is a lot easier than Darksouls and BloodBorne so far)
Oooh zig zag
You got the zig zag.
How did that hit me
Noooowwhh D:
Oh he fell down(out) (No he didn't)
DEMONETIZED D:
Are you kidding me.
I'm getting so gamered out.
Death count: Why can't we be friends~ why can't we be friends~
are you kidding me.
are you kidding me right now.
death count: It's over 9000!!!! (anime just for you poods)
Alright , first time I do this 🤔
Oh god it's an ogre.
I'd better start doing a lot of damage.
while he's still contain
oh god , no one's ever thought of that (indeed.)
Oh the red stuff that probably means he's about to attack. (wowies)
Physics breaking ogres (wat?)
*silence